is it possible to invent a computer that
computes anything in a Flash or do
problems exist that would stump even the
most powerful computers imaginable how
complex is too complex for computation
these questions are Central to a
fascinating conundrum called the P
versus NP problem P versus NP I think is
one of the great unsolved problems in
all of math and computer science or you
know really in in in all of human
knowledge if we're being honest
anyone who finds a solution could win a
handsome $1 million prize offered by the
clay Institute and this solution could
lead to breakthroughs in everything from
medicine to artificial intelligence and
even the perfect game of Mario Brothers
but it would come at a cost a definitive
answer to the P versus NP problem could
break your bank account and even lead to
the end of the internet as we know
it to find out why let's start with a
simple simple logic puzzle a robot
arrives in a foreign land where everyone
either always tells the truth or always
lies the robot reaches a fork in the
road with two choices One path leads to
Safety in the land of Truth tellers
while the other leads to Doom in the
land of liars a century appears but it's
unclear which group they belong to what
question can the robot ask to determine
the safe route here's some
options
and here's the
answer with this one question both types
of sentries would point to the correct
safe path allowing the robot to solve
the problem
quickly now what if the robot encounters
multiple centuries and dozens of
Pathways leading who knows where what
can it do to find safe
passage compared to the first problem is
a correct solution here proportionally
more difficult to find or is it
exponentially harder maybe there's a
shortcut that could speed things up or
maybe finding a solution to this complex
situation is nearly
impossible the question of how hard a
problem is to solve lies at the very
heart of an important field of computer
science called computational complexity
computational complexity uh is the study
of the inherent resources uh such as
time and space uh that are needed to
solve uh computational problems uh such
as factoring numbers for example and
especially it's the study of how those
resources scale as the problems get
bigger and bigger computational
complexity theorists want to know which
problems are solvable using clever
algorithms and which problems are truly
difficult maybe even practically
impossible for computers to
crack so how do computers solve problems
in the first place a computer's core
function is to compute these machines
perform basic mathematical operations
like addition and multiplication faster
than any
human in 1936 a 23-year-old British
University student Allen touring
developed a fundamental theory of
computation while attempting to solve a
problem about the foundations of math
touring claimed in a paper it's possible
to invent a machine which can compute
any computable sequence given enough
time and memory this simple theoretical
touring machine which includes a place
to store information and a device to
read and write new information based on
a set of instructions is the basic
framework for all digital computers to
come one of the key insights of computer
science is that touring machines are
mathematically equivalent to just about
any other programming formalism that you
know anyone has invented at least for
conventional computers inside a digital
computer data are represented as binary
bits sequences of ones and zeros and
these bits can be manipulated through
logical operations using a a branch of
math that preceded the invention of
computers called Boolean
algebra the basic rules of Boolean
algebra were formulated in 1847 by
English mathematician George buou
Boolean algebra formulates decision
problems yes or no problems that can be
asked in sequence to answer complicated
questions the output of a Boolean
function for any given input can be
represented in what's called a truth
table and it is either one or zero
true or false expressions in Boolean
logic consist of multiple variables
linked together by three logic gates and
or not these logic gates work like this
for an and gate when the inputs for both
variables X and Y are true the
expression evaluates to True otherwise
it's
false with the orgate the expression
evaluates to True when either X or Y is
true a not gate simply inverts the value
of a variable switching a true to false
or vice versa by using only these three
simple logical operations and building
them up into various configurations
Boolean formulas can operate like a
touring machine and theoretically solve
any computable
problem in 1937 an electrical
engineering graduate student Claude
Shannon demonstrated in his master's
thesis that the Boolean operations and
and or and not can be calculated using
electronic switching circuits a decade
later Bell Labs introduced the first
solid state semiconducting
transistor transistors are simple
electronically controlled switches with
three wires a control wire and two
electrodes to input and output data they
can be in one of two states on or off
representing either a one or zero true
or false transistors can be combined and
arranged in different configurations to
mimic the Boolean logic gates of and or
and
not by combining enough of these
transistors together on computer chips
in complex Arrangements called circuits
it's theoretically possible to compute
almost anything anything that is
computable that is more about that
later in the 1950s Hungarian American
mathematician and computer scientist
John Von noyman brought the modern
computer one step closer to reality he
developed the AR arure of the universal
electronic computer the same
architecture at work inside most
electronic Computing devices today from
smartphones to
supercomputers since the mid1 1950s when
the first transistor-based electronic
computers were built the technology has
swiftly Advanced by scaling down and
cramming more and more transistors onto
tiny chips computing power and speed has
nearly doubled every 2 years today
computers can perform trillions of
calculations per second but even that's
not always good enough there's a class
of problems that computers can never
solve a quandry Alan touring for saww in
the same paper where he conjured up his
calculating machine touring had the
insight and in fact proved that not
everything is computable the limiting
factor is not the hardware but instead
the software or
program computers solve problems by
following lists of instructions called
algorithms an algorithm just means a
step step by-step procedure for solving
a problem running an algorithm is
analogous to following the steps of a
recipe or an Ikea assembly manual here's
an example of an algorithm that sorts a
list of numbers from lowest to highest
it works like this take a random list of
numbers start with the first number from
the left which here is six now look
through the remaining numbers and
identify the smallest one which in this
case is three next swap the places of
six and three and you'll have the
smallest number in the group on the left
take a second pass this time starting
with the second number from the left
swap with the smallest and so
on after enough passes all the numbers
are sorted lowest to highest using this
simple
algorithm any problem that can be solved
by an algorithm is computable but by the
1970s computer scientists realized that
not all computable problems are created
equal some turned out to be easy While
others seemed hard for problems like
multiplication computer scientists found
really fast algorithms but for others
like optimizing the operations in a
factory they couldn't find any easy
solutions and it turned out that some
problems were so hard the only known way
to solve them could end up taking more
solution steps than there are subatomic
particles in the
universe thus the P versus NP problem
was
born so what exactly does p and NP mean
p problems or problems that can be
solved in polom time are the types of
problems that are relatively easy for
computers to solve the vast majority of
what we use our computers for on a
day-to-day basis you know you could
think of as solving various problems in
P from finding the shortest path between
two points on a map to sorting a list of
names alphabetically or searching for an
item on a list these are all examples of
polinomial problems a polom is a
mathematical function that can contain
variables raised to a fixed power or
exponent like n ^ 2 or n cubed the time
it takes a computer to solve P problems
grows polom as the input increases in
size given enough computing power all
problems in P can be solved by a
computer in a practical amount of
time now NP problems are a class of
problem problems that share a unique
feature if given the solution it turns
out to be quick and easy to verify if
it's
correct easily solved P problems are
contained within the class of all NP
problems because they can also be
verified relatively quickly in
polinomial
time however there's a class of NP
problems that are easy to check yet seem
difficult to solve in the first place
it's really helpful to think about
something like a jigsaw puzzle or a
Sudoku puzzle right we all have
experience that you know these could
require an enormous amount of trial and
error to to solve but nevertheless you
know if someone says that they solved it
it's much easier to check whether they
did if someone gives you a completed
hard puzzle like a large sodoku or
crossword the answers can be verified
much faster than it can be solved in the
first place it's the same for a computer
the reason these types of NP problems
can be more difficult for a computer to
solve is because as far as we know the
their complexity increases exponentially
as their input increases an exponential
function has the variable in the
exponent like 2 to the^ of
n here's an example of exponential
versus polinomial growth for the same
input with these hard exponential NP
problems the increased complexity of
large inputs can quickly exceed the
limits of what a computer can compute in
a reasonable amount of time and solving
them using Brute Force techniques alone
is practically
impossible could be uh doing that you
know from from now until the whole
universe has degenerated into black
holes and you would you wouldn't have
even made a dent in it over the years
mathematicians discovered clever
polinomial algorithms for some seemingly
difficult NP problems proving that these
problems were actually in the simpler
class P and making them solvable by a
computer this opened the door to the
question are all NP problems really P
problems
could every problem that is seemingly
intractable for a computer to solve
today turn out to be easy in the
future P equaling NP would have far
ranging consequences solutions to nearly
any problem would be well within our
reach AI would become smarter overnight
businesses could solve complicated
optimization and Logistics problems
boosting the global economy and
scientists could make once Unthinkable
breakthroughs maybe we could even find a
cure for the common
cold however if P equals NP that would
also mean that all current methods for
strong encryption security measures that
protect everything from your online
privacy to your crypto wallet would
instantly become obsolete it would be
hacker
heaven in the 1970s mathematicians
Steven Cook and Leonid Levan working
independently on opposite sides of the
Iron Curtain made important discoveries
that have come to Define find the P
versus NP problem they discovered the
idea of NP
completeness almost all of the
notoriously difficult problems in NP are
actually equivalent so if you could
prove one of those is equal to P you've
solved all of P versus
NP this is kind of like a veterinarian
realizing that even though toy poodles
and St Bernards look very different they
are in fact the same species and a
treatment that works on one would very
well work on the
other there are hundreds of known NP
complete problems and finding a single
solution would lead to breakthroughs on
multiple fronts including physics
economics and biology not to mention
computer science itself NP complete
problems include a host of famous
problems you may have heard of including
the napsack problem which involves the
most efficient way to pack items like in
a suitcase or the traveling salesman
problem which involves root planning and
navigation complicated NP complete
problems even underly everyday tasks
like figuring out how to deliver
millions of Amazon packages on time or
efficient and life-saving matching of
organ donors with
recipients and even mastering games like
Tetris or Candy
Crush all known NP complete problems can
be transformed into one another the most
famous of these is What's called the
Boolean satisfiability problem or sat
sat is one of the most famous problems
in computer science besides its
theoretical interest right it's a very
fundamental Workhorse problem in applied
computer science especially in software
verification sat is a decision problem
that asks for a given Boolean formula or
expression made up of n variables and
The Logical operators and or and not is
there a combination of true false
variable assignments for which the
entire formula evaluates to true
if so then it is said to be
satisfiable if someone can devise a
clever fast algorithm for the sap
problem making it easy to compute then
voila proof that P equals
NP however most computer science
researchers believe that P doesn't equal
NP and proving P doesn't equal NP has
turned out to be one of the hardest
problems in math and computer
science in the 1980s one promising
Avenue of research emerged called
circuit complexity the field studies the
complexity of Boolean functions when
represented as circuits the behavior of
Any Given Boolean function can be
described by its truth table however the
same truth table can be produced by
circuits of differing complexity as seen
in these two examples a Boolean function
circuit complexity is defined as the
total number of logic gates in the
smallest circuit which can compute that
function
researchers study circuit complexity to
understand the limits of computation and
to optimize the design of algorithms and
hardware for some Boolean functions the
minimum number of logic gates grows
polom as the number of input variables
increases these are said to have low
circuit complexity and are analogous to
p-class computational
problems functions where the number of
necessary logic gates grows
exponentially with increasing in put
variables are said to have high circuit
complexity one potential approach for
proving P doesn't equal NP required
researchers to identify a single
function known to be in the class of NP
that also definitely has high circuit
complexity in 1949 Claude Shannon proved
that most Boolean functions have high
circuit complexity so how hard could it
be to find one instance harder than it
[Music]
sounds alas researchers encountered a
mathematical roadblock called the
natural proofs barrier this barrier
implies that any proof that P doesn't
equal NP using known circuit complexity
techniques would have to have a bizarre
and self-defeating
character clearly a different way
forward was needed while most
researchers started looking for other
approaches some began to investigate the
natural proofs barrier itself leading
them to new questions how hard is it to
determine the hardness of various
computational problems and why is it
hard to determine how hard it is it's a
very meta area of computer science
called meta
complexity it has turned out that a lot
of the progress that one can make on
problems like the P versus NP problem
today you know involves sort of
self-referential you know uh arguments
involves sort of turning inward given
the limits of known techniques medic
complexity researchers are searching for
new approaches to solve some of the most
important unanswered questions in
computer science and crucially metac
complexity is intimately connected to
the question of whether provably secure
cryptography schemes even
exist one important current focus of
research is What's called the minimum
circuit size problem or
mcsp mcsp is interested in determining
the smallest possible circuit that can
accurately compute a given Boolean
function is there a simple solution
the minimum circuit size problem is a
problem about circuit complexity but how
complex is the problem itself
researchers suspect that mcsp is NP
complete but unlike many other similar
problems they haven't been able to prove
it a proof of mcp's NP completeness
would be a big step towards showing that
secure cryptography does exist and
recently there's been tantalizing
progress towards that goal like the
robot searching for safe passage in a
foreign land the pursuit of meta
complexity is blazing a trail for
theoretical computer science a path that
may lead to an answer to whether P
equals NP or not if civilization lasts
long enough you know I would tend to
think that probably problems like P
versus NP will someday be solved and my
main uncertainty is is it humans who
solve them or is it is it AI is it is it
is it pp10 that that that that solves
the P versus NP problem for us and then
will we be able to understand the
solution if it
[Music]
does